oui donc l'abstention historique et la
ville de marseille donc qui va skull
on va en parler justement avec hervé
manchon candidat europe écologie les
verts dans le 5e secteur de marseille
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france votre réaction tout
d'abord à ce basculement de la ville de
marseille
c'est avant tout la victoire des
marseillais ce mouvement que vous
présentez comme un mouvement d'union de
la gauche est aussi un rassemblement des
citoyens et d'un ensemble de forces
politique humaniste et écologiste qui
qui aujourd'hui représente un espoir
pour la ville parce que le projet qui a
été construit avec les avec les
marseillais les marseillais pour
construit avec tous et tous et tous ces
partis a aujourd'hui fait complètement
contrastent avec le bilan d'un quart de
siècle de mauvaise gestion de jean
claude gaudin et de son héritière
martine vassal qui vainquit qui perd qui
perd avant tout parce que elle a joué
sur sur la peur en parlant de chars
russes qui viendraient défilé sur la
canebière elle fait ridiculiser et elle
n'a pas défendu correctement le n'a pas
pu en tout cas défendre correctement le
bilan de ce quart de siècle de mauvaise
gestion à l'état lui même jusqu'à
proposer un changement et a critiqué son
propre bilan
hervé man show il ya eu lieu également
dans l'antre de tout l entre-deux tours
qui a été bouleversé par l'ouverture
d'une enquête sur des soupçons de
fraudes aux procurations dans le camp
des républicains là encore est ce que ça
a pu jouer selon ou sur les résultats de
ce soir
en fait ça fait des années que que tout
le monde parlait de c2c de ces éléments
qui porta en tout cas qui interroge et
qui interroge maintenant la justice
par contre c'est la première fois où
nous réussissons à voir apparaître dans
les médias des éléments probants les
éléments suffisamment probants pour que
oui ça ait pu un petit peu influencé le
le score du second but du deuxième tour
il n'y a - vient confirmer la bonne
dynamique qui était déjà engagée à
vendre avant ces affaires là au premier
tour vous parlez de bonne dynamique on
peut parler d'un printemps marseillais
mais aussi à noter elle finalement le
bon score de la gauche pour ces
élections qui renaît en quelque sorte
oui c'est une renaissance fait une
renaissance peut-être une renaissance de
la gauche mais encore une fois c'est une
renaissance d'un projet humaniste
sociale écologiste qui était fortement
attendue parce que les marseillais n'en
pouvait plus de devoir couper des arbres
créer des autoroutes urbaines voire les
écoles tomber en ruine vent la culture
les lieux de culture fermés et la
pollution augmente et avec en plus la
pollution des navires un tourisme de
masse qui qui n'a apporté 2 qui n'a pas
apporté grand chose en terme de en
termes de bénéfices pour les marseillais
cette année jusqu'à vendre des parts
publiques pour en faire des hôtels cinq
étoiles
merci beaucoup et hervé manchon d'avoir
répondu à nos questions en direct sur rt
frange rappelle que vous êtes numéro
deux de la liste le printemps
marseillais